para votar é e sobre a aura como já fui
apresentar vamos falar aqui hoje de
repressão ea readaptação à formulação é
entre outros fins
isso ao contrário aqui é nomeadamente
este projeto que é o projeto ipa foi o
que trouxe aqui e como venho aqui falar
em fazer falar assim essa desculpa hora
e só avançou hoje que o que o ciro é
neste projecto porque gera uma
curiosidade por materiais e objetos que
estavam estragados sentido de destino é
é a capacidade para guardar os erros da
partida aquela roda servia para o outro
tenho um carinho com uma parte de
chegada do chassi e aproveitar e fazer
sempre qualquer coisa um boneco um braço
aproveitar um abraço pra fazer outro
médico seja neste sentido foi sempre
habituado é reciclar também tem uma
história de vida que me ajudaram é é
desenvolver esta crise da minha mente um
boato em solo e estranha mãe todos os
metais
depois de aprender a fazer uma coisa em
salta para todos nós que era depois de
todo o oriente prender esse é o papel
estavam todos no chão ela pegava os
papéis todos juntava que o tudo pra casa
pra casa passar alguns dias eu via uma
amiga dela faziam anos
aí ela procurar um melhor embrulho mais
bonita cedro e fazer um embrulho
impecável no meu pessoal é zero
minha mãe com o mesmo embrulho fez duas
pessoas felizes e protestantes dizer
as coisas foram acontecendo foi um
importante sempre é vontade de guardar
ver a minha vozinha aguardar os shakes
parte de todos este tipo de atitudes e
foram crescendo dentro de mim e foram
vara é o vai promover e valorizar todos
aqui pra vocês eu estou práticas normais
se viu isso
e pra mim não é necessariamente acho que
pode ser sempre uma nova vida e pronto
eu sou formado em administração e nível
de instrução também sempre um caso esta
esta filosofia
isto são duas ilustrações minhas é
exatamente o aquilo que eu estava a
aplicar está com pressão para quatro
noites para fazer uma ilustração neste
caso uma vaca é com o corpo em forma de
pacote é que é uma caveira que foi feita
com uma folha de raio x para vocês
perceberem os pacotes light são
recicláveis podem originar em coisas
destas
cria se houver a criatividade associava
podem criar coisas destas
o raio x como já disse isso aqui só
acorda entrevistas revistas de moda de
revistas qualquer coisa serve para para
para criar neste aspecto estão a
condicionar criativamente ou seja não
sou propriamente eu sigo o que vou fazer
ou não não há aqui um briefing orientado
e pré definido eu não sinto que vou
pintar a qualquer coisa não é bem assim
que funciona
você é mais como uma história com vai
surgindo faz recortes de imagens que as
interessantes para no chão e isso aí as
formas com cindo e vou criando a partir
daí eu seja eu sou só um interveniente
né um completamente
um feeling e boom não sou o cristo já
que já estão feitas e eu só vou dar um
jeito e orientar e criar a minha forma é
até mais ilustrações deste ano também é
que são recortes de revistas como
processo criativo
isso era uma guitarra quer construir
paulo isso é um trabalho artístico não é
não é uma peça funcional é o que eu
construí uma uma cidade retratando a
forma como vive a música na altura é
isso é uma forma de comandar a guitarra
para o lixo e para muitos seria lixo pra
mim nunca na vida se eles acham que ela
forma tinha muito valor para mandar
paulista
serão dois roger estavam partidos os
dois é na parte de trás da banda papel a
volta é hoje que os nexos de de moda
marketing e plante consegui dar uma nova
vida um só diz que que a partida não
eram nada zero hoje é esse projeto vai
falar da represa é um projeto que
precisa ter nesse propósito inicial foi
comprar madeira de palestras do conceito
virar constante das coisas materiais de
outras espécies um amigo meu quando um
saxofone alguém que não dava uma ou
outra peça e eu a partir daí fui do ecc
de materiais como foi trabalhar
essas foram as primeiras peças foram
surgindo complete com como era do
palestra
isso permite nos perceber que podem ser
inúmeras coisas com com materiais que
nós menosprezamos obviamente não têm o
mesmo a mesma é convidado ou mesmo o
mesmo acabamento e outras peças estrela
condicionante do material tanto se fala
do material que pinho regra geral que
tem algumas condicionantes escultóricas
seja horizonte são limitados é que temos
mais uma espécie de um cargueiro de
janeiro aqui as dificuldades mas maior
dificuldade tem consistência em
conseguir parcerias que possam fornecer
matérias província de forma contínua e
estuprar que conseguiria criar uma linha
de produção em que eu tenho acesso à aos
materiais conseguir
é uma produção contínua de peças já
definidas
outra dificuldade prende-se com
capacidade produtiva que ela está viva
as minhas colecionando espaciais de
ferramentas é e produção comerciantes
que eu tenho é que estamos fazendo na
madeira de plantio também é que nesse
caso fica natural é que é uma coisa
muito simples tanto ficou çom de forma
natural em qualquer telemóvel pois o
telemóvel e amplifica o som é uma coisa
muito simples e que nos permite ter um
objeto foi reciclado e que no g3
ele nos dá uma função é fantástica pela
qual uma questão de dinheiro é por norma
uma loja comprar uma coisa normal é que
lá uns então é móvel
aqui temos mais peças também tudo com
parentes aqui é o que eu aprendi com
este processo com esse processo aprendi
tudo é passível de ser reanimado
através do sucesso certo e dá alguma
criatividade técnica é certa se
conseguimos criar sem falar uma coisa e
depois surgem estas peças neste caso
esse dinheiro aqui do lado direito foi
um campeão que tinha umas pernas
eu achava piada aquelas pernas foram os
cada uma coisa que não é muito normal e
eu decidi não é que ela vá fazer alguma
coisa com ela espera agora espero que
até confunde aí surgiu a idéia surgiu e
idealista que era um filme que ele
representava a amorim cork veio da
esquerda foi um campeão foi feito
através de um processo vá conforme foi
um é um processo industrial que eu tenho
nenhum eu tenho um escritório em casa
não sabia que queria fazer e eu tive que
fazer alguma coisa pela fifa é
inspirador paulich eu não ia estava
certo e sabia então se ele por uma
pesquisar pesquisar o que faz com
aspirador é para um inspirador pode
fazer vai conforme front pois cria uma
máquina com este inspirador
um permite fazer vaca conforme que é um
processo industrial que estava a falar
pra mim fazer formas daquelas que o mall
só uma parte
santos promete fazer moldes de uma parte
e que permite tirar este formas entre
outras também
aqui temos uma duas guitarras um mero um
casaquinho de uma prima que foi paulo
isso é outra uma guitarra
é que estava mesmo no lixo em que estava
um cara chato isso fizeram duas curvas
para o telemóvel
essa gente fica aí as cunhas e e e
funcionou
é assim uma idéia muito engraçado sic
são outras peças que queiras por ser um
lixo
ora temos nenhum é o campeão do mundo
estranho aproveitaria vaza achava o
início mas nunca teve de mandar uma bola
daquelas paulistinha lá um louco também
estava estragado aproveitei o ovo é que
ele é o odonto aqui ou aquela grande
reação todos nós conhecemos faz tanta
partida da nossa cultura portuguesa e
disse por que não transformar aquilo num
candeeiro vista que vai sempre a lista
geral
por que não transformar num candeeiro
que não os nexos uma criança qualquer
ficou sem o certeza a fruta mas pronto
estava no lixo ou apropriado em termos
uma chaira também estava no lixo é que o
que ele está foi um bairro em que tinha
um câncer do que atuava estragava é e eu
não vou mandar o primeiro pau lixo em um
bairro que também estava estragado disse
rui por um cão é e eu não vou me adaptar
isto e há obviamente de uma nova vida é
essa torneira aqui é um dos meus
trabalhos favoritos é também o atleta
que também já não serve pra não era
funcional em termos torneira deixava
passar água por todo lado e eu não estou
a ser um candidato e pronto e foi o
grande destaque ao fórum sob meu também
que tem como encomendou o trabalho lhe
que eu ia um fogão antigos usavam
antigamente o equivalente a um camping
ganhasse hoje em dia é mais aquilo era
velha guarda
quero é tão é fabricar ovos ao erro
agora o que falta a primeira falta é
aprender com este projecto é como
conseguir tornar este projeto viável é
normal pensar aquilo que se propõe um
ciclo criativo ciclagem falta aprender
novas técnicas novas formas materiais e
também alguns processos criativos que
permitam alcançar novas peças diz
orgulhoso
é é no final depois criar a peça é é
fantástico ver verá ao criado com um
qualquer lixo e que agora passará a ter
uma função e passasse funcional
é que o pretendente as outras pessoas
seria isso agora já não é earl faz parte
da nossa vida e que nos permite é usar e
e desfrutar é eu acho que esse tipo de
atitude a gente faz valorizar mais os
objetos gente faz valorizar mais o
cemitério os materiais que esse é um
problema que nós hoje em dia temos
grandes pólos com uma facilidade
incrível e nós perguntamos o que vai
acontecer aqui o em alguns casos o
clássico mas eu não sou assim tão grande
é e pronto e com isso deixou a
apresentação do projeto obriga a
continuar só votar